hello guys and welcome to another video
so in this video we have been given a
new look at the soccer TV show in the
form of two new images and a sneaky
video clip that I'll show you guys in
the first image here we have an
Inquisitor and wow what an awesome
looking shot this is this Inquisitor
here is looking absolutely badass now
online there's a lot of speculation
going around on who this Inquisitor is
is it the eight brother is it Barris is
it a completely new character some
people even saying is it Starkiller all
people are saying is this a brainwashed
Ezra now let me know who you guys think
it is in the comment section below
anyway in the first image we have an
image of Ahsoka and Sabine Sabine is
seen having a shorter hairstyle which
she had in the rebels TV show which in
Ahsoka trailer she was seen having a
longer hairstyle and judging by the
background and sabine's hairstyle I
believe this could be a live action
Recreation of the ending of Sorrows
Rebels and also there is a sneaky little
Easter egg in the scene if you look
closely Sabine is C in having a
lightsaber and this is no other than
Ezra's lightsaber which Sabine can also
be seen using Ezra's lightsaber and a
leaked Ahsoka trailer which was shown at
Celebration an actor herself has been
undergone lightsaber training so it's
safe to assume that Sabine will be using
Ezra's lightsaber in this series in the
next image we're seeing Ahsoka Taino in
a ship now nothing to really point out
about Ahsoka apart from that her liqueur
is longer which we already knew and saw
in the other images and trailers because
in the Mandalorian show it was short of
for stun reasons but it seems I've
figured out a way to combat this now
which is great it's now accurate to the
character but there also seems to be a
star map in the background it looks like
the plotting or looking for something
now I assume this is Ahsoka trying to
find Ezra's location and a big part of
this series will probably be trying to
locate Ezra now let me show you guys a
short little clip now this clip comes
from that leaked trailer that I was
speaking about before and in the clip we
see Ahsoka and Sabine line in the
direction of a pergol or virtual however
you pronounce it and those are the
hyperspace Lane creatures that we have
seen in Rebels and also demand Lauren
but also in the shop where we see Ahsoka
and Sabine Sabine is seen having the
shorter hairstyle again and Ahsoka is
also wearing a different outfit so this
just makes me wonder this is also set at
the start of a series where Sabine has a
shorter hairstyle or is this later in
the series where she decides to cut her
hair again the only reason why I'm not
sure if it's before after is because
Ahsoka has a different outfit though but
what do you guys think let me know in
the comment section below and also guys
if you're new to the Channel please
consider subscribing and liking the
video thanks for watching guys